southern nevada health district has  launched an effort to reach out to those  in danger of drug  overdoses this linkage to action mobile  unit is funded by the cdc  and will work with community providers  to help connect vulnerable populations  to needed services can include anything  from  wound care referrals to medication  assisted therapy  referrals to other medical needs such as  behavioral mental health  and identifying any barriers that may be  keeping the individual from getting the  support they need related to substance  use  the l2a mobile outreach unit will allow  staff to prioritize locations where  resources are most needed  including homeless encampments tunnels  areas where overdose spikes have been  identified  as well as rural areas